hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem
klitzekleinen real life info video hier
auf meinem kanalhaie erst mal und zwar
wollte ich euch zwei sachen sagen bzw
doch zwei sachen sagen ich hätte
wahrscheinlich sogar noch mehr sagen es
ist ein kleines video clips und ich
wollte jetzt einfach mal anfangen mit
der erste sache und zwar ich habe euch
ja schon damals gesagt dass ich jetzt
schon habe vor einer woche oder so und
ich hab die noch nie wirklich an gehabt
und ich mein ich habe ja schon gesagt wo
ihr die kaufen könnte steht noch immer
in der beschreibung das muss ich glaube
ich jetzt nicht mehr sagen bevor er
wieder leute meckern und ich hab mir
auch mühe damit gegeben
ich würde einfach sagen ich jemand
schritt nach links
also das sind jetzt die conti shirts die
finde ich besonders cool weil das
einfach sowas clean ist ich habe lange
darüber nachgedacht wie ich das am
besten design könnte das jetzt einfach
relativ klein es ist ein bisschen blöd
in französin franzosen land in
frankreich heißt irgendwie sowas wie
vagina das ist ein bisschen blöd jetzt
aber ich möchte jetzt auch nicht das
ganze design ändern weil ich das so
einfach ganz cool finde
und ich möchte jetzt nicht fedcon
krofdorf schreiben weil ich weiß nicht
was finde ich irgendwie so mag ich nicht
so deswegen habe ich einfach drauf
geschrieben sie am besten nicht an wenn
ihr in frankreich seit oder zieht an und
machten fotos derjenige der ein konzert
anhalt und 111 ii vom eiffelturm 8 bot
er kriegt von mir keine ahnung was
kostenlose dass das wäre echt witzig
also wenn man mit einem konzert nach
frankreich das war schon witzig ich
wollte nur sagen mein anderer schuldner
wäsche das ist aber genauso gedruckt ich
habe mir das anders shirt mit einem
blauen t-shirt geholt also dass anderes
symbol auf dem blauen t shirt und jetzt
in grau mit diesem weiß drauf finde ich
ganz gut und ich glaube auch weißes
kommen auf einem blauen t-shirt also
circa in der farbe form einer meiner
hose ist glaube ich auch ganz cool
deswegen ich wollte euch das noch mal
zeigen wie's aussieht weil viele leute
gesagt haben höhe wie sieht das ganze
dann eigentlich aus ist man die angaben
im shop kann man schlecht beurteilen
also ich geh jetzt mal ein stück nach
hinten damit ihr seht wie das aussieht
so ich denke jetzt habt ihr das ganze
gesehen wie das shirt auszieht dann
wurden auch die letztlichen fragen
beantwortet es wird auch noch einen
designer shop geben aber das werde ich
dann noch mal irgendwann in einem video
in dem video nebenbei erwähnt wo ihr
euch selber sachen wie beispielsweise
eine tasse design könnt oder dinge wie
eine n die hülle oder ein kissen so
alles was ihr haben wollt wenn die leute
sagen ich finde dieses kann oder die
sich anders so cool ich möchte es auch
noch offen
becher drauf haben oder so dann könnte
das darauf machen das werde ich aber
noch mal eben bei einem video sagen und
würde ich sagen kommen wir jetzt schon
zur zweiten sache die ich ansprechen
wollte und zwar longboards
beziehungsweise so kleinere skateboards
ich bin ja nicht so der krasse longboard
fahrer weil ich eigentlich mal so der
autofahrer bin und sportaufnahmen ist
auch kein komplett egal meine story
jedenfalls hat mir us kock aus schweden
die haben so ein kleines nicht penny
bord penny bord finde ich ein bisschen
doof
sorry an alle die jetzt irgendwie penny
bord fahren und sich dann angegriffen
fühlen das ist ja eine eigene meinung
die ich hier habe und die möchte ich
euch ja gerne auch sagen und zwar penny
wenn ich ein bisschen blöd weil einfach
alles aus plastik ist und halt nicht so
hochwertig und ich habe mir dann
überlegt und penny bord kostet ihnen wie
auch so 100 bis 200 euro da kann auch
noch teurer werden
und ich hab mir dann gedacht was gibt's
dann in dem dreh in dem geld umfang
blabla voran sachen die so ein bisschen
weiß nicht hochwertiger sind und
deswegen wenn ich jetzt auf dieses das
modell heißt fröhlich verlinkt euch das
in der beschreibung falls ihr lasst euch
eventuell selber bestellen wird und der
shop ist halt echt cool dass hier sehen
wir us corp der sonne unterschrift und
alles also dieses board finde ich extrem
geil ich bin damit schon mit kran
crafter ascend ein paar anderen leuten
schon mitgefahren die fans auch alle
relativ cool
die einzige sache die mich ein ganz
klein bisschen daran stört ich meine ich
keine kritik ist es das ganze wenn man
damit fährt ihr seht schon da sind ein
paar schrauben drauf wo wir uns am
anfang ein bisschen gefoult haben
das war halt so
wir sind halt eine downhill mit dem ding
gefahren und haben dann die erste kurve
angetreten und jetzt aufgefallen man
darf damit nicht so hart lenken wie mit
einem longboard also diese kugellager
sind relativ weich oder hart sehr
weicher und wenn man da draufsteht und
man bewegt sich im netz ein bisschen
mithin mit dem hinteren fuß zum schein
also das ist halt relativ klein wenn ihr
meine hand seht und ich die da drauf hat
ihr seht ihr schon wie geocaching drehte
schon dass es relativ klein ist uns
vielleicht sogar noch kleiner als im
penny bot ich hatte noch nie wirklich
ein penny bord nur im laden gesehen
es ist noch kleiner als ein penny bord
aber es hat zum beispiel breitere reifen
aber diese breiteren reifen machen es
trotzdem relativ nicht gefährlich zum
fahren aber es ist ein anderes
fahrgefühl und man muss sich erstmal
eingewöhnen
allerdings hatte ich ja noch nie
wirklich ein longboard also ich habe man
das womit ich einmal einem video
mitgefahren mir deswegen hatten die mich
auch angeschrieben der shop man mit mir
hier kann schnell mal testen und ich
habs jetzt getestet ich finde es
eigentlich cooler als ein longboard es
ist nur krasse gewöhnungssache also ich
möchte die ganze zeit über dieses ding
reden ich wollte euch das einfach nur
mal empfehlen für alle die jetzt sagen
nilsson penny bot finde ich jetzt blöd
habe ich mich fast anders als longboard
jetzt nicht wieder rummeckern dass ich
hier julie christie co ich kriege nichts
von dieser firma ich möchte euch einfach
nur sagen was ich selber cool finde und
das mache ich ja schon die ganze zeit
seitdem ich auf youtube in und ich
find's einfach weiß ich jetzt ein
bisschen ist gefällt mir sehr gut auch
von der farbzusammenstellung also das
ist jetzt schon holzdesign es gibt noch
ganz andere designs die stelle noch ganz
normale longboards er allerdings ein
bisschen hochwertiger die preise gehen
noch also das kostet 130 euro oder so
das geht können für sonnen bord geht es
locker fit ich kenne leute die bezahlen
für longboards 300 euro kollege werner
das siehst ich finde einfach dass ganze
bord hat was also ich finde auch das es
einfach hier in den reifen es liegt an
den in den rollenden sieht richtig cool
aus wirklich wie bei sommerrallye oder
so und ich meine uskok ich glaube die
fans oder release also ich hab mich noch
ein bisschen von mir finde ich auf jeden
fall sehr cooles bord ist es
gewöhnungssache dann könnt ihr auf jeden
fall einfach mal vorbeischauen müsste ja
nichts kaufen einfach mal durchschauen
und ich bin doch die longboard sind
solltest mir schon vom tisch runter
relativ cool und das sollte auf jeden
fall auch sagen also des t shirts habe
ich euch ja gerade schon gezeigt ich
zeig euch nochmal die hochspringer aber
das wird super toll geklappt glaube ich
jedenfalls wollte ich euch die beiden
sachen eben mal kurz zeigen und was ich
mir gesagt ich sag noch mehr sachen ich
mache bald wieder reallife videos auf
luca film ich habe da schon zwei neue
formate richtig cool geplant
beziehungsweise einfach mal etwas aus
zwei formaten besteht ich weiß nicht was
da alles kommen wird
ich verlege euch den kanal wenn ihr
immer noch dran seid würde ich mich
freuen wenn ihr da vorbeischaut und
bitte mal alle die gerade noch dran sind
konnen punkt in die beschreibung
schreiben das wenden franzose dass ich
denke also es wäre ganz witzig weil dann
kann ich auch sehen wie viele leute von
euch jetzt gerade noch das video
anschauen
also schreibt mir da mal konnten die
kommentare von punkten sowie auf diesem
t-shirt und ja ich verlinke euch alles
in der beschreibung also wenn ihr dabei
dem shop vorbei schauen wollt ich finde
es auch richtig cool was die für sache
machen und schaut einfach mal vorbei
schob er den schatz vorbei und ich habe
bei meinen real life kanal vorbei sorry
das ist ein blödes info wieder kommen
musste aber sowas muss halt auch mal
sein und dafür kommt heute abend
noch ein cooles video heute abend wieder
heute auch ein maskottchen